he said when uh he walked in and we had
not yet started recording that uh that
you have a story about us meeting and
let me tell you that when I when I hear
this when I when when I hear that
somebody has an old story about meeting
me it gives me great anxiety
you excuse me you go a [ __ ] can't
and then you started sucking your own
dick and as I tried to do it you hit me
over the head with like a sack of
potatoes and it forced my dick into my
own mouth and then I found out the jerk
then I found out that your dick was
prosthetic and you were just joking but
I had sucked my own dick by the end of
the night meeting you so you don't need
to have any anxiety where was this in
Vegas yeah I don't know so uh what
actually happened was we and my wife Kay
was with me yeah I say that because
um
I get anxiety because there have been
different versions of me and and if you
met a certain version of me then the
story is going to be horrifying I think
that's true I always wish
that I had met nitrous oxide you okay
because I was a huge nitrous oxide
enthusiasts were you for years we did I
did the Critics Choice Awards
this is a long time ago and I was doing
so much nitrous at that point that I
would go on live television do what I
was doing then run back look on my notes
hit a couple of nitrous cartridges and
then go back on stage because my joke
about nitrouses would only lasts like 20
30 seconds would be the best thing to
get pulled over doing because the cops
like if you've been doing nitrous and
you're like yeah a little bit but what
are you gonna do about it because now
it's over
laughs
that's it it's all gone right it only
lasts 20 30 seconds or as long as you
keep inhaling it right exactly well and
that's why after creative Swiss Awards
we went and we went to the Bel Air and
Kate and I just partied we knew each
other since College we've known each
other for like 20 some years and so we
just sometimes we just go into that mode
and we just partied and we were so
excited and when we woke up the next day
there were like a thousand whippet
cartridges because we had bought the
hundred packs you know so we just did
you guys are like hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds that night and we was
joking there's a whole like bar I don't
know how we ordered it but it was a full
bar on a room service card like I guess
we just been like bring it all damn it
bring every last one of them and we just
and so Kate woke up and she was like oh
man we gotta stop doing nitrous and like
as she said that I was like oh I found
another 100 back and she's like after
that
gotta stop doing nitrous right after we
finish that but I think we we met you in
incredibly
uh grateful amiable
authentic Stevo because you really
quickly kind of said oh man I'm a huge
fan and I just I love doing stand-up and
it's kind of new to me but it's a while
ago it's at the Laugh Factory okay and
so I kind of I thought that was amazing
and it was a great moment for me because
you know there's a lot of people that
didn't serve up a stand of comics and
they started doing stand-up comedy like
a Jeremy Piven or a lot of YouTube guys
and a lot of comics or were just like oh
God yeah sure you're doing stand up but
the way that you talked about it just in
our brief interaction I realized no this
guy has a lot of respect for the form
and then later subsequently as I sort of
heard your stuff and came to understand
I realized you really were a Storyteller
but you were also kind of doing that as
stand up and doing stand up within that
and I feel like I saw all that on you
like in you right away and then you were
so nice to Kade and then you talk to
Kate's cousin Giselle who's just [ __ ]
awesome she's like a goth mom right now
and she and her husband's so great too
and she's a huge fan of yours and so you
blew her [ __ ] mind because she
expects you so nervous to me and she
expects to be like oh it's nice to meet
you and yeah I'm Stevo and I gotta go
and you just straight up stood there for
10 minutes kind of answering questions
and asking about her life and all this
stuff and she'll she'll never forget
that I mean it was the coolest thing and
that's the other thing I noticed about
you I was like yeah this guy will
definitely take 10 minutes of his time
to permanently alter somebody's life in
terms of their stories and who they you
know because there's a thing never meet
your Heroes I just saw you kind of being
like if you meet me and I'm your hero
you're gonna get as much of me as I can
give you I think that clip was awesome
but not as awesome as my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what I've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions my
first books Five star rated on Amazon
and I have learned that this one will be
too so get the autograph copy right now
at stevo.com
yeah dude